a major medical breakthrough in the
treatment for alzheimer's
the fda approved a new drug abu kanunab
appears to actually slow the progression
of the disease
a local doctor from the cleveland clinic
lou rubo center for brain health
had a handful of patients involved in
that study and i spoke with him earlier
today
this is the first medicine that targets
the underlying biology of alzheimer's
disease
we've never had a treatment like this
for this condition it's been 18 years
since the last
new medicine was approved those
medicines primarily target symptoms so
to be able to slow down the disease
uh is something that i i didn't know
we'd ever get to this point so
so it is really exciting it hopefully
ushers in a whole new era of the
treatment of alzheimer's disease
so for for those reasons we're ecstatic
today
i can tell you're excited about it i'm
very excited about it
this is this is something that was
several years ago
we didn't think was possible um and and
there was a lot of
negative uh thoughts about being able to
slow down the disease
a lot of uh pharmaceutical companies
which we
rely on to develop our therapies left
the space of alzheimer's disease and
that's too hard
and so so this is a day that that i
think changes that and says the
investment that people made
in a center like ours that keep memory
alive
makes for us that the rovo family has
done for us to say
let's invest in alzheimer's disease
that's this is the payoff i i think for
that and so i'm very excited
a lot of work to be done but this is a
really exciting
milestone in the history of treating
patients with this disease
as you can see in that video there the
drug is given through in
infusion kind of like an iv so it's not
like you just give somebody a pill and
then they go on their way
each of those doses takes about 30
minutes and the patient is monitored the
entire time
so for that reason alone it's going to
take some time to ramp up
dr ritter tells us that the lou roubo
center has six of those infusion chairs
however there could be 800 to a thousand
local patients
that could benefit from this new drug